Charles Ponzi.
Bernie Madoff.
Billy “Fyre Festival” McFarland.
History is littered with the misdeeds of conmen
who pulled the wool over the public’s eyes
and made a killing.
Some, like Frank Abagnale - the model for
Leonardo Dicaprio’s character in Catch Me
if You Can - pulled off cons so big they’ve
become legendary.
But not even Abagnale could compete with our
subject today.
Gregor MacGregor was many things: soldier,
pirate, pathological liar.
He was also the man who pulled off the biggest
con in history.
In 1821, MacGregor arrived in London with
tall tales of a new Latin American nation
where fortunes could be made.
Using his deadly charm, MacGregor managed
to not only swindle banks, investors, and
ordinary people out of the 19th Century equivalent
of billions of pounds, he indulged in fabrications
on such a colossal scale that even Europe’s
governments were fooled.
But how did this Scottish nobody create a
con so big it swallowed an entire continent?
Join us as we explore the life of Gregor MacGregor,
the most amoral adventurer to ever live.
Birth of a Conman
When he came to tell the story of his birth
many years later, Gregor MacGregor would never
let two details remain the same.
He was born into high Scottish nobility.
He was descended from the legendary outlaw
Rob Roy.
His ancestors were adventurers who founded
Scotland’s doomed colony in the Darien Gap.
The odd thing was, he needn’t have bothered.
Gregor MacGregor’s background was interesting
enough even without his tall tales.
Born on Christmas Eve, 1786, MacGregor came
from, well, the MacGregors, a Jacobite Clan
that had only just been relegalized after
100 years as outlaws.
While his dad wasn’t the chief, as MacGregor
would claim, his family were still notable.
His grandpa had been an officer in what would
become the Black Watch.
His father was a ship captain.
In short, young MacGregor had action in his
blood.
And in 1803, when MacGregor was only 16, that
blood would drive him to seek adventure in
the British Army.
As luck would have it, 1803 was the year the
Napoleonic Wars broke out, and MacGregor was
hurriedly posted to the island of Guernsey
to defend against French invasion.
But that invasion never came.
Instead, MacGregor wound up living a deeply
unadventurous life of waiting around.
Not that his time on Guernsey was all a waste.
It was while on assignment that MacGregor
met his first wife.
Maria Bowater was the sort of catch young
enlisted men used to dream about.
Her father was an admiral, her family members
were MPs.
Oh, and they were absolutely, stinking rich.
In no time at all, MacGregor had charmed his
way into marrying her, much to the horror
of her family.
No sooner had they tied the knot then MacGregor
was using his wife’s money to buy himself
the rank of captain and get transfered down
to Gibraltar.
But while the weather may have been nicer
on Spain’s southern tip, life was still
boring.
For the next four years, MacGregor did nothing
but stand around, waiting for a French fleet
that never came.
Then, in 1809, just as MacGregor was planning
to give up and return to Scotland, excitement
finally arrived.
The year before, Napoleon had invaded Spain,
engulfing the whole of Iberia in the Peninsular
War.
Sensing a chance to give Napoleon a black
eye, the British decided to intervene.
And that’s how Gregor MacGregor found himself
in Portugal fighting Napoleon’s forces.
Yet even in the heat of combat, MacGregor
couldn’t settle.
In October, he sold his rank of captain and
departed the British Army for the Portuguese
one.
But by May, 1810, he’d also got bored of
the Portuguese and resigned again.
Come summer, 1810, MacGregor was back in Scotland,
feeling as unfulfilled as ever.
But he was no longer merely “Gregor MacGregor.”
On leaving the Portuguese Army, MacGregor
had started telling people he’d been knighted
for his service, and was now “Sir MacGregor”.
It was a stupid lie.
A dumb, egotistical little lie that shouldn’t
have changed anything.
Yet change things it did.
When people didn’t question it, MacGregor
realized just how easy lying about even huge
things really was.
It was a revelation that would soon take the
young man to some very bizarre places.
Life with the Liberator
In April, 1812, a ship pulled into port near
Caracas, Venezuela, and disgorged a slender
Scot in his mid-twenties.
It had been two years since MacGregor had
left Portugal disillusioned, and much had
happened.
In 1811, his wife had died, and his in-laws
had cut him off financially.
So MacGregor had left Britain, in search of
something - anything - that would keep his
mind occupied.
Luckily, 1811 wasn’t short of opportunities
for a would-be adventurer.
That year, Venezuela had declared independence
from Spain, kickstarting the South American
Wars of Independence.
So MacGregor had decided to get involved.
No sooner had he landed than then-Republican
leader, Francisco de Miranda, had appointed
him a cavalry officer.
But it’d be an even bigger name in Caracas
society that MacGregor would soon get involved
with, thanks to his 1812 marriage to Josefa
Antonia Andrea Aristiguieta y Llovera.
Josefa, you see, was cousin to none other
than Simon Bolivar.
Not that his newfound connection would immediately
work out well for MacGregor.
Just months after his marriage, MacGregor
was in flight, running for safety as the First
Venezuelan Republic fell to Spanish forces.
Francisco de Miranda was captured, while both
MacGregor and Bolivar only escaped - heading
in opposite directions - by the skin of their
teeth.
And so began the period of Gregor MacGregor’s
life where he kept crossing paths with the
greatest figure in Latin American history,
only for it all to keep going horribly pear-shaped.
In 1813, for example, MacGregor volunteered
in the New Granada army, only to be assigned
to a remote border town and miss Bolivar’s
Admirable Campaign and founding of the Second
Venezuelan Republic.
In 1814, the two both wound up in Cartagena
after the Second Republic fell, but Bolivar
was forced into exile while MacGregor got
trapped in the siege of the city.
Finally, MacGregor reconnected with Bolivar
in Haiti in early 1816 and joined his latest
campaign.
It was a campaign that would nearly cost MacGregor
his life.
By now, most of Venezuela was back under Royalist
control.
Bolivar’s plan was to land men at strategic
points along the coast, then coordinate a
mass uprising.
Put in charge of 600 troops, MacGregor was
quietly dropped at Ocumare.
Unfortunately, the plan instantly fell apart,
Bolivar was forced into retreat, and MacGregor
and his men were left standing on the shore,
their mouths dangling open as their ride disappeared.
They were trapped in Royalist territory, over
300km from the nearest Republican stronghold.
They had no boats, limited ammunition, even-more
limited provisions, and were surrounded by
swampland.
At that moment, it must’ve seemed to the
600 men like death was a certainty.
They hadn’t counted on MacGregor’s talent
for self-preservation.
In a remarkable feat of leadership, MacGregor
led his men on a march right through Royalist
territory, executing innumerable brilliant
maneuvers to keep the enemy at bay.
He tricked the Spanish troops into walking
into swamps.
He had his men charge blockades on foot and
punch right through.
It was like watching LeBron James lead Elmer
Fudd around a basketball court, with the dimwitted
Royalists fumbling every play while MacGregor
ran circles around them, laughing.
And yes, as far as we know, we are the only
YouTube channel delivering history via Space
Jam 2 analogies.
You’re welcome.
After weeks of running battles, MacGregor
finally led his men into the safety of a Republican
town.
When news leaked of his 300km trek, the Republican
camps exploded.
MacGregor became a hero overnight, his name
celebrated across the continent.
Suddenly, everyone wanted to serve under him,
the guy who’d married into Bolivar’s family,
and then out-Bolivared Bolivar.
But, sadly, this isn’t a video about Gregor
MacGregor, revolutionary general.
It’s a video about Gregor MacGregor, conman
extraordinaire.
Those soldiers all clamouring to serve under
him didn’t know it yet, but MacGregor would
soon lead countless of their number into early
graves.
Third Time’s the Charm...
In the wake of MacGregor’s daring escape
from Ocumare, Bolivar personally awarded him
the Order of Libertadores - hopefully while
shuffling awkwardly and mumbling “sorry
I abandoned you back there, bro.”
But MacGregor was disappointed.
He hadn’t gone through hell just to get
a shiny new medal.
No, he wanted a promotion.
A raise.
Something to show the world he was a hero.
If Ocumare wasn’t enough for his cousin-in-law,
MacGregor would just have to go one bigger.
That fall, mercenaries up in Pittsburgh began
to whisper about a Scottish man doing the
rounds, hiring people for a private invasion
of Spanish Florida.
The Scot was a Portuguese knight, a Venezuelan
hero.
More to the point, he was very generous.
Anyone who joined him was being given titles
to huge estates in Florida.
For the rough and tumble men of Pittsburgh’s
dive bars, it seemed like a no-brainer.
Which is how in June, 1817, MacGregor was
able to sail for Amelia Island, Florida at
the head of 200 mercenaries.
There was just one minor catch.
MacGregor didn’t actually own the land he’d
been dishing out to his private army.
But, hey, while spoil a good invasion, right?
Not when everything was going so well.
And it really was.
When the only Spanish garrison on the island
saw all these armed Americans, they assumed
it was the head of a full-blown US force and
surrendered.
Now all MacGregor needed to do was press his
advantage, take a few more forts, and he’d
soon have another victory to rival Ocumare.
But that didn’t happen.
Instead, MacGregor declared Amelia Island
the Republic of East Florida, and then simply
settled in to enjoy getting drunk and sunning
himself.
For MacGregor’s men, this must’ve been
a “what the-?”
moment.
Then MacGregor started paying them in Republic
of East Florida dollars he’d made himself
and it became a “Whaaa-?!”
Finally, one morning in September, the mercenaries
awoke to find MacGregor had taken the ship
and remaining money and simply sailed away,
leaving them to their fates.
At that point, they probably couldn’t even
summon a squeak of surprise to show how they
felt.
Following the Florida failure, MacGregor badly
fell out of favor with Bolivar.
So he tried again.
In 1818, MacGregor sailed back to Britain,
hired 500 more men, and this time tried to
conquer Panama.
Landing a force of 200 at Porto Bello, he
took the city…
...and then went straight back to lounging
around in the sun, drinking rum and failing
to do anything that might stave off a potential
Spanish counterattack.
This last bit proved important when the potential
counterattack became an actual counterattack
and MacGregor was forced to flee, once again
leaving his mercenaries to their fates.
By now, the Scot was starting to look less
like the capable general of Ocumare, and more
like a shallow egotist who’d just happened
to get lucky.
But his name still carried enough shine for
MacGregor’s surviving men to follow him
on one last invasion.
In October, 1819, MacGregor landed outside
a Royalist holdout on Venezuela’s coast.
It was the exact same checklist as Amelia
Island and Porto Bello: MacGregor takes city?
Check.
MacGregor gets drunk rather than organize
defenses?
Check.
When things go south MacGregor sails away
and leaves his men to their fates?
Double check.
This time, those fates were particularly gruesome.
After the Spanish retook the city, they lined
up all of MacGregor’s surviving mercenaries
and had them shot.
In the aftermath of MacGregor’s third colossal
screw up, Simon Bolivar didn’t so much throw
the book at him as crush him beneath an entire
library of disapproval.
Bolivar declared his cousin-in-law a traitor.
He issued a decree that any Venezuelan who
saw MacGregor should kill him on sight.
But while this was the end of MacGregor’s
time as a revolutionary warrior, it wasn’t
the end of the man himself.
When he resurfaced, it was going to be with
a con that would go down in history.
The Con
is
On
Sprawling along the Caribbean coasts of modern-day
Nicaragua and Honduras, the Mosquito Shore
is exactly as unappetizing as its name suggests.
It’s a hot, wet, desolate place where life
is cheap, disease is rife, and mosquitoes
omnipresent.
In April, 1820, Gregor MacGregor hopped off
a boat and vanished into the mangrove forests
of this tropical Hell, desperate to lose himself.
By now, it wasn’t just Bolivar who wanted
him dead.
The Spanish, the Americans, the British…
all, for varying reasons, had MacGregor’s
name on a hit list.
In the movie of MacGregor’s life, this would
be the low-point, the part where all seems
lost.
But you know what always comes after the low
point in any movie script?
The part where the hero triumphs.
While hiding on the Mosquito Shore, MacGregor
came into contact with one of the local tribal
leaders, a guy who styled himself King George
Frederick Augustus.
Being a natural charmer, MacGregor got the
guy drunk and spent a few days partying with
him.
By the time he emerged from the king’s hut,
weary and hungover, MacGregor was clutching
a title deed to 8 million acres of tribal
land.
This piece of paper would become the basis
for his audacious next move.
Back in MacGregor’s native Britain, the
nation was gearing up for the coronation of
George IV.
There were street parties.
Dignitaries from all over the world.
In fact, there were so many dignitaries no-one
noticed when one arrived from a country that
didn’t exist.
His Serene Highness Gregor MacGregor the First,
Sovereign Prince of the State of Poyais and
its Dependencies, and Cacique of the Poyer
Nation arrived in London in summer, 1821.
Just like with MacGregor’s fake knighthood
in 1810, no-one questioned his absurd new
title.
To understand why, you have to remember when
this story is set.
In 1821, a whole bunch of new nations had
just exploded into existence: Mexico, Gran
Colombia, Argentina, Chile, Paraguay, Peru.
For Londoners, it wasn’t much of a stretch
to believe Poyais might be among them.
Especially when the Poyais envoy was related
by marriage to Simon-freaking Bolivar.
But MacGregor did more than just trade on
his connections to fool people.
Under the pseudonym Thomas Strangeways, he
published a guidebook to Poyais, detailing
the nation’s government, its geography,
its climate, its architecture.
This was serious imagination, something Tolkein
would’ve been proud to write, and it was
shot through with glimpses of a utopia.
There was the soil, so fertile it could support
three harvests a year.
There were the riverbeds, where lumps of gold
lay along the banks.
And there was the fact that, uniquely for
Central America, Poyais had no tropical diseases.
Trust us, that last one will soon seem bitterly
ironic.
But why did MacGregor go to all this trouble
to invent a fake country?
For an answer to that, you need to look to
London’s Scottish communities.
That same summer, the Poyais envoy began visiting
them.
He was offering them an opportunity, he said.
An opportunity not just to better their own
lives by moving to Poyais, but an opportunity
to establish Scotland’s first viable colony.
A chance to make their country into a global
player.
All they had to do, Gregor MacGregor told
his fellow Scots, was to buy one of these
plots of Poyais land he was selling.
Fertile land that would set them for life.
Faced with such an offer, who could refuse?
The Bubble
By the fall of 1822, interest in Poyais was
running rampant.
The first boatload of Scottish settlers had
just departed for the country, and a general
bubble in Latin American securities was expanding.
So when MacGregor asked a bank to underwrite
Poyais bonds, they simply nodded and handed
him £200,000.
Using that money, MacGregor opened Poyais
consulates across Britain, adding to the scheme’s
veneer of legitimacy.
For MacGregor, these were the salad days;
a phrase which means the heyday of something,
which is an odd choice when you consider how
boring salad is.
By winter, investment in Poyais bonds had
generated over a billion pounds in today’s
money.
And MacGregor was still selling land to gullible
Scots!
The second boat of settlers departed in January,
1823.
But there’s one problem with dispatching
boatloads of settlers to a non-existent country.
What do you do when they finally arrive?
Well, let’s find out.
In November, 1822, the first ship reached
the Mosquito Shore.
As the boat approached land, the Scottish
settlers all donned their fanciest outfits,
and fired the gun so a Poyais boat would come
out and guide them to the capital.
Instead, the gunshot echoed across the empty
waters and mangrove swamps, answered only
by deafening silence.
At first, the settlers assumed they must’ve
made a navigation error.
So they all had their stuff unloaded onto
a deserted stretch of coast, and sent the
captain off to find Poyais.
It’s worth noting that these were not young,
hardy types desperate for adventure.
Most of those caught up in the Poyais scheme
were older folks looking for an easy retirement,
or families with young children.
Surviving on a deserted stretch of tropical
shore was definitely not within their skillset.
In March, 1823, the second ship joined the
stranded settlers.
Incredibly, everyone still assumed their navigation
was off.
Even when the captain of the first ship returned
and said “so, I’ve sailed all up and down
this coast and there’s no Poyais,” they
told him, “err, obviously there is.
Duh.
Try again.”
So off the captain went again.
And the now hundreds-strong crowd of settlers
settled down to wait again.
That same month, a hurricane battered the
Mosquito Shore, destroying supplies, and wrecking
the remaining ship.
Then the rains came.
Thick, heavy, endless rains that left the
settlers soaked.
Finally, in the wake of the rains, came the
mosquitoes.
If you’ve ever been to the tropics in rainy
season, you’ll have seen just how thick
the air can get with mosquitoes carrying yellow
fever and malaria.
On the deserted shore, the insects mobbed
the unprepared settlers, biting them, infecting
them.
One by one, the abandoned Scots began to die.
Babies passed away in their mothers’ arms.
Elderly women died, wracked with malaria.
Of the 200 or so Poyais settlers who reached
the Mosquito Shore, it’s estimated over
two thirds were killed by tropical diseases.
It was a massacre by neglect.
A death sentence as sure as a firing squad.
The only reason anyone survived is because
a ship from British Honduras just happened
to pass and alert the colonial authorities.
For the rest of 1823, the Royal Navy was overwhelmed
evacuating the survivors and intercepting
ships headed for Poyais.
By the year’s end, they’d stopped five
more settler ships, each carrying hundreds
of people.
Had they reached the Mosquito Shore, it’s
likely the death toll of the Poyais scheme
would’ve topped a thousand.
Back in London, news of the disaster first
broke in October, 1823.
Immediately, lots of very angry people began
looking for Poyais’ charming envoy.
But they were too late.
MacGregor had fled England just before the
story arrived, taking as much of his ill-gotten
cash as he could carry.
It was a horrific denouement to the wildest
con ever pulled.
Unbelievably, it still wasn’t over.
Gregor MacGregor wouldn’t be done with the
Poyais scheme for another fifteen years.
No Bad Deed Goes Unrewarded
From 1823 to 1838, MacGregor pulled his Poyais
con again and again.
Incredibly, he never faced any serious punishment
for it.
Even after the harrowing tale of the survivors
got out, no-one in Europe could accept Poyais
didn’t exist.
MacGregor had simply lied too big.
In the same way our brains wouldn’t be able
to process the revelation that, say, Hawaii
wasn’t real, people in the 1820s just couldn’t
comprehend the idea that Poyais was fictional.
When MacGregor settled in Paris, the French
government even made him an advisor on Latin
American affairs!
This despite MacGregor restarting his fake
bonds scheme in France.
Although the scheme itself was busted in 1825,
MacGregor successfully blamed his French partners,
and again got away Scot free.
He even returned to London and got more bonds
underwritten for £800,000.
While no investors bit this time, it wasn’t
because of the tragedy on the Mosquito Shore.
It was because the Latin American securities
bubble had just burst, and no-one wanted to
risk another.
For the next few years, MacGregor hawked his
scheme up and down Britain.
While he never again hit the big time, he
always had just enough money coming in to
keep the fiction going, to keep people believing
in Poyais.
Finally, in 1838, MacGregor’s wife Josefa
died.
Suddenly alone in gloomy Britain, the conman
seems to have at last given up on his con.
That October, MacGregor got on a boat and
sailed back to Caracas.
He never mentioned Poyais again.
So… this is the moment, right?
The moment when MacGregor finally gets his
comeuppance.
I mean, he’s headed back to Venezuela, the
very place Simon Bolivar left orders that
he be killed on sight.
If you’re hoping for a moral end to this
story, best switch off now and construct one
in your own head.
See, Bolivar had died all the way back in
1830, by which time he incredibly unpopular.
With Bolivar’s name now mud, everyone was
like “I mean, do we really need to kill
this random Scottish dude?”
So they let MacGregor land.
They even let him request an audience with
the government.
At which point, Lady Luck dropped an utterly
undeserved gold nugget right into MacGregor’s
lap.
Remember Ocumare, the one time that MacGregor
actually acted like a hero?
Well, General Carlos Soublette did.
He’d been under MacGregor’s command during
that mission, and seen the conman at his best.
Since he’d never followed MacGregor to Florida,
or Porto Bello, or even heard of Poyais, he
had no idea of MacGregor’s true character.
And now Soublette was a member of Venezuela’s
government.
When he saw MacGregor, he basically let out
a cry and threw his arms around him.
That was how, in 1838, Venezuela came to reinstate
Gregor MacGregor’s rank in its army, hand
over twenty five years’ back pay, and give
him a generous pension.
For the next seven years, MacGregor lived
in Caracas, wealthy, happy, and respected
by all.
He finally died a peaceful death on December
4, 1845, without having ever repented of his
cons.
Sometimes, life really is unfair.
Today, it’s estimated that, between the
Poyais scheme and all those times he abandoned
his men, Gregor MacGregor was responsible
for the deaths of 500 people.
Yet even though he never got his comeuppance,
his story offers us all an excellent moral
lessons.
It’s easy to fall into the trap of assuming
that the world is fair.
That maybe bad things sometimes happen, but
- in the end - everything will always balance
out.
The tale of Gregor MacGregor laughs in the
face of this.
Here was a man who treated other people as
disposable trash, only there to fuel his own
fantasies.
A man who sacrificed literally hundreds of
lives to the God of his ego.
And he never tasted justice for even a single
second.
Unique among figures we’ve covered, MacGregor
offers us a bleak but necessary warning.
Sometimes, good doesn’t triumph.
Sometimes, the happy, wealthy, respected people
are the ones who have caused untold suffering.
Gregor MacGregor may be long dead, but there
will always be others out there like him,
charming and amoral.
If his life shows us anything, it’s that
we should always be on the lookout for these
people.
Even when they seem to be the most respectable
types you could ever hope to meet.